[Musique]
mais
les rencontres des arts et de la science
sur le thème humains demain c'est le
thème d une cité qui auront lieu du 17
au 25 mars prochain notamment au grand
théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines
lionel 20,7 à bonjour et bon à
l'initiative de de ces rencontres est
une cité cd deuxième l'année dernière
c'était le thème était le temps
aujourd'hui l'humain et on va parler
beaucoup d'intelligence artificielle est
noble mais pas que aux portes et il y
aura des spectacles et des tables rondes
et je crois pour préparer ces rencontres
vous avez été aidé par alexander d'une
boum
alexey alekseev je ne sais pas
alexis d'italie alexis grinbaum vous
êtes vous êtes chercheur vous êtes
physicien philosophe vous êtes chercheur
au laboratoire de philosophie les
sciences de co2 saclay et et spécialiste
notamment de physique l'information
quantique
alors pourquoi avoir choisi ce thème
pour ces rencontres
lionel ne sais pas pourquoi parce que
lorsqu'on choisit un thème on choisit en
général 2 en 2 ans avance le premier
c'est sur le temps qui était un de temps
vu par le prisme de la science physique
thème un peu conceptuel en essais de de
choisir un thème qui nous concerne nous
dans notre dans notre quotidien le temps
nous concerne dans le quotidien
on essaie aussi de faire un peu de
prospective et la question de l'humain
demain ou de l'humain aujourd'hui nous
concerne avec tout ce qu'il contient
tout ce qu'il aura à l'intérieur de ces
de ces rencontres on va parler vous
parler d'intelligence artificielle
d'augmenter on va parler de philosophie
on va avoir des philosophes des
anthropologues des
du spécialiste de l'éthique des
nouvelles technologies etc etc c'est
comment est ce qu'aujourd'hui
l'homme vit vie avec ses sept sortes de
bouleversements de la science mais un
bouleversement qui le concernent au
quotidien
quel est son avenir commence à en partie
aujourd'hui et quelles vont être les
conséquences le maîtrisera t-il dans
l'est dans les années qui viennent
voilà on est vraiment dans des choses
extrêmement pratique qui nous concernent
au quotidien on a quasiment tous des
téléphones portables donc on est con
sydney contraire
alors ces questions-là télévisuelle avec
cette question et que vous posez c'est
humain demain mais déjà qu'est ce que
c'est qu'être humain c'est souvent la
question de base
c'est la question de base et si de la
question par laquelle on va comment vous
commencez ces rencontres puisqu'elles
sont faites de tables rondes de ce
spectacle est également de cinéma on
essaie d'aborder cette thématique de
l'humain demain par différents angles
par différentes sources et la première
des tables rondes où il y aura une
philosophe et une anthropologue va être
comment est-ce qu'on définit définir
l'humain comment est-ce qu'on définit
l'homme
c'est simple c'est mal voilà c'est pas
moi qui vais vous le définir non pas
maintenant
aujourd'hui alors alexei grinbaum vous
avez aidé justement la programmation de
notamment des données sur tout
qu'est ce qu'un message qu'il faut faire
passer quel but que voulait faire passer
auprès du grand public puisque c'est
après tous celui là qui sera intéressé
par ces prix par les spectacles et par
les rencontres telles les deux messages
le premier message
et épistémique c'est quelque chose qui
est important pour les jeunes de 50 ans
mais aussi pour les vieux pour tout le
monde qui s'intéressent aux sciences et
c'est ce message est le suivant on ne
peut pas vraiment aujourd'hui penser le
main juste avec de la biologie ou de
neurosciences le main se définit par
rapport aussi aux objets qui l'entourent
et ces objets sont numérique
informatique aujourd'hui en grande
partie il ya des algorithmes partout
l'homme fonctionne dans un monde dans un
contexte et pour penser le main il ne
suffit pas de penser son corps
biologique
il faut penser aussi sa condition par
rapport au numérique et donc
cette j'utiliserai même aux convergences
des sujets qui viennent de la biologie
et du numérique au niveau scientifique
mais aussi au niveau des utilisations
est importante ça c'est le premier point
[Musique]
donc si vous voulez faire de la biologie
apprenez à écrire du code
si vous êtes un pur informaticien qui
n'a jamais pensé aux applications vous
ne serez pas un très bon informaticien
donc pensé à toutes ces choses voilà
voilà pour penser à ces choses là il
faut avoir un regard est large et
deuxième deuxième message
ça n'est pas limité à quelques
laboratoires obscurs dans les centres de
recherche scientifique
après bien sûr tout le monde voie du
rebond il ya des smartphones donc on les
utilise tous les jours donc on
sélectionne n'est pas limitée aux
laboratoires
mais il n'ya pas que ça il a l'art
lalart parce que l'art c'est le reflet
de l'histoire de l'humanité ce sont des
choses qui entrent dans la culture et
dans l'histoire continue de l'humanité
il n'y a pas de rupture jusqu'à
avant-hier c'était un monde sans le
numérique aujourd'hui c'est un autre
bond n'ont hélas pas de rupture dans la
continuité de cette histoire de
l'humanité et l'art particulier ne
permet de la saisir de l'avoir de la
touchait cette continuité et de la
représenter il est et est donc l'art est
essentiel dans cette construction de
l'humanité continue à travers des
siècles
et quand ces technologies quand ces
résultats scientifiques sont représentés
dans l'art ça veut dire qu'ils font
partie du socle de notre histoire mais
c'est vrai que l'art est souvent un peu
en avance par rapport à la politique
d'autres ports par les politiques sur ce
domaine de l'art et à sa ronde à penser
et là alors dans le spectacle au théâtre
de la danse vous
avait un certain nombre de spectacles
qui sont intéressés rassembleur c'est
toujours les artistes sont toujours
intéressés aux nouveaux médias ont tout
simplement soit pour les utiliser sur
pour en être les premiers utilisateurs
poids soit pourront trouver des
applications auxquelles les inventeurs
des créateurs n'avait pas pensé soit
pour les détourner soit pour les
questionner mais c'est à dire que la
position de l'artiste allait il ya
quatre positions possibles mais c'est
intéressant ce que dit ce que dit
alekseï et nous dans la construction des
rencontres je vous disais qu'il y avait
ces trois angles d'attaqué mais la
partie scientifique pour moi il était
extrêmement important de travailler sur
la partie scientifique avec en
l'occurrence au spécialiste de l'éthique
des nouvelles technologies parce que ça
permet d'avoir une vision extrêmement
globale et précise
une personne qui peut nous orienter sur
le sur le sur le choix des sur le show
et tables rondes et en fait ces
rencontres in cité c'est pas autre chose
que j'ai pas si on peut parler de
partage du savoir
vous parliez de la façon dont le citoyen
doit s'emparer de ces questions là il
peut s'emparer de ces questions là il
faut qu'elles sortent des laboratoires
est en fait en faisant non en invitant
des scientifiques pas que des
scientifiques
il y aura également des écrivains des
artistes mais à ces tables rondes c'est
aussi les faire sortir du laboratoire
ils sont très demandeurs de sortir du
ring de leur laboratoire pour parler au
grand public en termes tout à fait tout
à fait intelligent mais il ya un partage
du savoir un partage des questionnements
j'ai dit et l'idée n'est pas d'en dans
ses approches et on le verra sur la
partie artistique d'avoir une approche
univoque de l'humain demain une approche
catastrophique sensationnaliste
c'est-à-dire tout d'un coup on parle
d'intelligent this way sera très
excitant soit ça fait on parle d'hommes
augmenté soit ça excite soit ça fait
peur non en fait faut sortir sur quelque
7 de cinématiques voilà de cette
problématique des dichotomies là et
essayer d'avoir une voix là de livrer
quelque chose d'assez de plus sage
objectif pas dans ce partage du savoir
et des questionnements et c'est
l'objectif de ces de ces rencontres
alors parlons un peu de la programmation
artistique parce qu'elle est l'essentiel
de ses skis à d'autres professions
artistiques et tables rondes
quels sont les meilleurs il ya beaucoup
d'argent qui sont concernés ils théâtre
et à la danse théâtre et à la danse et à
la musique difficile m'a également
puisqu'on travaille avec l'ugc noailles
voisin de l'ugc il ya une parfaite
correspondance entre le contenu des
conférences à dire on pouvait faire un
fléchage à saint-grégoire et des tables
rondes et les tabous qui suit les rires
des semailles saric tag voilà qui
suivent qui précède ou glee spectacle et
puis les films c'est à dire qu'on n'y a
pas une table ronde qui ne va pas avoir
de lien en lien avec un spectacle ou un
film c'est c'est assez étonnant c'est
vrai que le cinéma s'est emparée de la
question tout comme l'année dernière on
compare les du temps le cinéma s'est
emparé du temps il ya très longtemps
il ya très très longtemps il s'est
emparé de la question du voile à d'une
mairie des nouvelles technologies il ya
également très longtemps le spectacle
vivant dans la programmation va dans une
dans la programmation on a bon on a sept
7 spectacles premier spectacle ma qui
m'intéressent j'ai vu des images tout à
l'heure déjà l'écran c'est c'est sans
objet parce que ça c'est sûr c'est un
spectacle de figure c'est un spectacle
de danses d'acrobaties cendre et elle
figure aussi notre rapport à la machine
à savoir oui c'est un monstre enfin
aurélien bourse forme aurélien bory à
acheter un rom kick et le metteur en
scène le concepteur de ce projet a
acheté un repos de l'industrie
automobile et l'a mis sur une scène et
sur ce robot à côté de ce robot il a mis
deux acrobates danseurs
le robot est manipulé en coulisses par
par un technicien est en fait tout le
tout le tout le travail sur 100 objets
s'appelle sans objet c'est la peur
initial de cette machine dont on voit
etc non sans la force qui est incroyable
et peut broyer les deux acrobates qui
sont dessus et puis petit à petit les
acrobates danseurs vont apprivoiser cet
opus et c'est cet objet la cette machine
là il va y avoir une sorte de
communication et de
entre la vraie relation entre l'homme et
la machine on part de cette peur pour
arriver à une maîtrise et un dialogue
réel entre les deux et sa figure
finalement tout tout ce qui nous
concerne tout ce qui nous fait peur dans
le genre l'intelligence artificielle
mais crise en ct sur ce sujet là autre
spectacle
autre spectacle que je pourrai dont je
pourrais parler c'est soft love qui est
une sorte de traduction à la scène du
film de spike jones qui s'appelait à
chaque donneur et qui est la vie d'une
jeune femme avec un assistant choix
qu'on appelle un assistant personnel une
intelligence artificielle robots
personnels qui va qui va lui dire
comment s'habiller etc et ce robot
contre toute attente ce robot va
développer une sorte d'affect pour pour
ça ça ça j'ai pas certains propriétaires
et finalement nous on va se retrouver en
empathie mais avec cette intelligence
artificielle personnel vous êtes assez
sachant que c'est un robot et racisme
qui souhaite un très intéressant ce
rapport qu'on doit voilà vous pouvez
très bien savoir que ça n'est pas un
humain et à avoir un rapport affectif
émotionnel et mes sept jours selon les
enfants d'ailleurs comme l'ont les ans
frappe seul avec n'importe quel objet d
une sorte d'animisme naturel chez des
enfants que l'on retrouve en
l'occurrence canton en canton et
finalement ce conte
on va faire je pense pendant ces
rencontres c'est d'aller au delà de ces
dichotomie je sais que c'est un robot
donc bon rythme pour moi j'ai juste une
petite chose voilà mais vous pouvez très
bien savoir que c'est un robot et
pourtant vivre avec
est-ce que vous allez participer à un
débat autour de frankenstein notamment
est ce que il ya beaucoup de docteurs
frankenstein au jeu court qui manipulent
des choses qui leur échappe
on fabrique des choses qui nous
échappent et
c'est bien ainsi mais on les fabrique
pas sans contrôle et sans limite et
d'ailleurs je rappelle que même dans le
roman frankenstein de mary shelley que
vous avez cités quand le monstre demande
aux médecins et victor frankenstein le
monde qui ne s'appelle pas prendre le
monde lui demande de lui faire une
copine 1 et le médecin refuse donc même
ce médecin fou a quand même des limites
il n'est pas si fou que ça rhin et là
des contraintes il va pas tout faire et
dans le monde réel aujourd'hui oui nous
fabriquons des machines qui apprennent
au delà de ce que nous avons programme s
nous ont déterminé donc des machines qui
seront autonomes
oui les machines qui vont aller au-delà
de ce qui a été
me bats octet par octets par le
programmeur mais il ya des contraintes
voilà je vais renvoyer au programme deux
entités on peut aller sur le site sur le
site internet voilà merci beaucoup
lionel masse et à merci beaucoup alexei
grinbaum donc c'est du 17 au 25 mars
humains demain les rencontres in cité
merci beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]